here is
Florida Congressman Byron Donalds
smacking down Democrat Democrat activist
Chuck Todd on NBC talking about how uh
taxes are not for reparations they're
actually to fix things in society you
realize that President Trump has added
more to the deficit than Joe Biden
I think of it as kovich
that is not true because we raised
numbers we raise more Revenue than CBO
projected if you bring in more money
than your projections are how are you
adding to your deficits joint and if you
pay if somehow you keep cutting taxes
but more Revenue comes in the government
that math doesn't work overtime you can
have it in the first first year due to
some various accounting uh tricks but it
doesn't work that is not true the
purpose of tax policy is to raise
revenue for the federal government not
to equalize Society after the Trump tax
cuts were passed more tax revenue has
come to the federal government that at
any other time in the history of our
nation those are the facts raw dollars
can happen because we do it and a
percentage of the economy one more thing
House Republicans are asking for sure
which is they want fewer IRS agents they
want fewer attempts to try to properly
uh get tax receipts into the federal
government's coffers I have never
understood the resistance of extra IRS
agents uh unless you knowingly cheat on
your taxes oh that first of all that's
that's salacious and you know that most
Americans by far pay their taxes and
they do it honorably well House
Republicans and frankly the Republican
party is concerned about is having IRS
agents go after middle-class families
and small business owners when you have
that many more agents it's not to go
after the rich it's to go after the
middle yes that's what it's for so if
you're if you're paying what you're
supposed to pay then you should have
nothing to fear you would make the
assumption that IRS audits are up that
they're they're putting out more liens
on the American people that's not true
that data is not there all Joe Biden is
trying to do is find every possible
nickel out of every couch from Every
American to pay for his radical spending
why would we do that listen let me
contrast for you when we passed the tax
cut in jobs act CBO said it was going to
cost two trillion dollars it's actually
not true what ended up happening was the
Federal Government took in a trillion
dollars more than CBO actually projected
um um the economy grew another one
litigate the tax cuts because what
happened with covet we don't know how
much this paid into everything but it
certainly looks like there were going to
be fewer revenues coming into the
government but we don't know In fairness
news now there's no litig there's
there's no ability to litigate this
because of what happened with covet and
the extra space that is not true Chuck
in 2019 we took in more Revenue than we
ever have in the history of our nation
as much of a percentage of our economy
than we ever have as a nation that was
2019. tax receipts are still up now you
may be watching that going wait a minute
wait a minute Byron how does that make
sense Trump uh cut taxes and then
suddenly the government got more money
well you know what happens guys when you
have more money in your pocket you start
spending more money than their sales tax
and a whole bunch more or you start
opening more businesses then there's
payroll tax and a whole bunch more
businesses start putting more money into
the economy that when the government
gets out of the way that's when the
economy chugs along beautifully but
Byron is of course he's completely right
it is not the job of the government to
take money from some people to do what
it wishes to maybe make it seem like we
all are exactly the same that is not the
job of the government and you're gonna
have to kill you're gonna have to steal
from an awful lot of people and you have
to kill an awful lot of people to make
that happen which is why in communist
and socialist society so many people end
up dead
[Music]
thank you